[Music]  Adam Levine is spilling all about baby  number two with Ellen DeGeneres do you  know if it's a boy or a girl it is a  girl having another girl are you gonna  have more children friend you want a big  family don't you I want a lot I like I  have thrive in chaos yes I I really  genuinely enjoy it and Behati likes it  too we love it she was known the child  so yeah  oh really though she wants like a lot  wants like a hundred babies but like wow  Adam and his wife Behati Prinsloo that  second child is due early next year the  couple welcomed that their first  daughter dusty rose last September and  we gotta say fatherhood it looks good on  the maroon 5 frontman we were born to be  a parent that's what we're here for  really yeah all the other great but it's  not what we're here for  [Music]  you